MALE SPEAKER: Hello, and
welcome everyone to a very, very
special event today.
We have a very
special guest here.
He greeted me in my mother
tongue when he met me.
He's traveled all
over the place.
And not only that, he
has a lot of insights
that he's gathered
from different places,
different events in
history and time,
as well as distilled these
insights into some bestselling
books.
Eric Weiner is the author
of "The New York Times"
bestseller "The
Geography of Bliss,"
as well as two other books.
He's here to discuss his latest,
"The Geography of Genius."
It's been called smart,
funny, and utterly delightful.
Some people have said
this is his best book yet.
The book has-- the earlier
book, "The Geography of Bliss,"
has been translated
into 20 languages.
A number of high
schools and universities
have incorporated the
book into their curricula.
I remember personally
when I read the book,
I was so moved I wrote about it.
And it was just a
fantastic phenomenal read
about different
places in the world,
and what is their
connection to bliss
and their idea of happiness?
I think in terms of
introducing Eric,
I feel that the best-- he's
best introduced perhaps
in his own words.
So let me just quote
something that he's written.
He says, "I'm an
author, speaker,
and a former
correspondent for NPR.
But I prefer to think of myself
as a philosophical traveler.
My interest-- my
obsession, really--
is the intersection
of places and ideas.
It is at this
intersection, I believe,
where the most fascinating
aspects of life unfold.
[INAUDIBLE] our
search for happiness,
spiritual fulfillment,
or creative expression."
With that, for you, sir.
ERIC WEINER: Thank you.
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you for that
very nice introduction.
I appreciate that.
I'm delighted to be here.
And I want to
begin with a story,
because who doesn't
love a story?
This is about a place
where a lot of brilliance
was happening in a
very concentrated area.
Incredible innovation.
And no, I'm not talking
about Silicon Valley.
I am talking about
Florence in the year 1489.
So let's time travel back there.
And the place is practically
run by one very wealthy family
known as the Medici.
The Medici were great
patrons of the arts,
and there were powerful.
And the big cheese
in the year 1489
was Lorenzo Medici, who went
by Lorenzo the Magnificent.
I don't know if he called
himself that or others did.
Maybe it was on
his business card.
But he was quite impressive.
He was a poet and a diplomat
and a great patron of the arts.
And one day he's walking
outside the palace grounds
and he notices this
young stone cutter
who can't be more
than 14 years old.
And the kid's pretty good.
He's working on a statue
of a fallen Roman god,
except the teeth
aren't quite right.
It's an older
statute, an older god,
but the teeth are
all new and perfect.
And Lorenzo says, kid.
It's not an accurate
representation of reality.
Look, old men like me
have decayed teeth.
The next day, Lorenzo
comes back and notices
the kid has taken his advice
and put in some gum decay
and made it look very realistic.
And Lorenzo was
blown away by this.
And what does he do?
He invites the kid into
his home to live almost
like a member of his family.
Gives him the best teachers
and the best materials
in the world.
In other words, he invests
heavily in this kid.
And it was a wise investment,
because today the kid
is known by his first
name, Michelangelo.
And the point of the story,
which we'll come back to-- I
want to set it aside for
a moment-- the point--
the question, rather, that
I'd like you to ask yourself
is, who was the genius?
Was it Michelangelo
who is certainly
a well known name and one
we associate with genius?
Or was it Lorenzo the
Magnificent, a lesser known
name, but someone who
perhaps without his involved
and his investment, we wouldn't
know the name Michelangelo?
Or another possibility.
Was the true genius
the city of Florence?
Was it the place?
Genius.
What do I mean by genius?
It's a big word.
Do I mean just intelligent?
Someone with a high IQ?
Absolutely not.
Have you heard of Marilyn
vos Savant, anyone?
High IQ.
220.
Perhaps the highest
ever recorded.
She hasn't accomplished,
with all due respect to her,
that much in the way of
creative achievement.
William Shockley.
Should be a familiar name here.
Nobel Prize winner,
inventor of the transistor.
One of the fathers,
really, of Silicon Valley.
IQ of 140.
Not so high.
Not bad, but not so high.
So I'm talking about
creative genius,
genius where you're creating
something for the ages.
And now if you apply
for a US patent,
you have to meet three criteria.
You have to invent
something that's
new, useful, and surprising.
You need all three.
You know, if I were to
invent a new coffee mug that
was fluorescent orange,
well, that would
be new and vaguely useful
because I could spot it
in the dark, but
not so surprising.
You haven't made
that conceptual leap.
I couldn't invent a coffee
mug with no bottom, which
would definitely be
new and surprising, not
particularly useful.
If I invent a coffee
mug that doubles
as a flash drive and
folds in your back pocket,
now we're talking
about something.
And also, I believe strongly
you cannot separate the creative
act and the recognition
of the creative act.
You can be doing the most
amazing work here in Google.
If it's not
recognized by someone,
it's almost as if
it doesn't exist.
Which is sad, but true.
So really, one important
aspect of genius, and maybe
the most important, is that
it is a social verdict.
That we all agree as a
country and as a culture
who the geniuses are.
If you're tinkering in your
garage and you're recognized,
then you're a genius.
If you're not, you're just some
guy tinkering in his garage.
You may be recognized
years later.
But if it takes a
village to raise a child,
as the African proverb
goes, it takes a genius
to raise-- I'm sorry.
It takes a city
to raise a genius.
That many people.
Now there are a lot of myths
surrounding genius, myths that
are partially true and
which can be helpful,
but are myths nonetheless.
One is that geniuses
are born, right?
This goes back, actually,
to the 19th century
and an odd English scientist
named Sir Francis Galton who
wrote a book called "Hereditary
Genius" who believed
genius was 100% genetic.
And we still hold
on to that belief
that when someone is a child
prodigy, like a Mozart playing
the piano at age four and
composing at age eight,
we think it must be genetic.
In fact, psychologists
now estimate
that somewhere between
10%-- that genetics
account for somewhere
between 10% and 20%
of the genius puzzle.
Important, but not
the most important.
Another myth is that geniuses
are made through hard work,
and that it's all hard work.
You've probably heard of the
10,000 hour rule, this notion
that you need to put in at
least 10,000 hours over a decade
to achieve mastery,
if not genius.
And I don't want to be
dismissive of hard work.
It's important.
But there are lots of
hardworking people in North
Korea, but very few
geniuses, right?
And it's not that
there's anything wrong
with them genetically.
It's that the third element
is missing, which is place.
So I believe that
geniuses are not born,
geniuses are not made,
geniuses are grown in the soil.
The seed matters in the plant,
but you need to water it,
and you need to have
the right climate,
or nothing's going to happen.
And it's always a
relationship, really,
between the genius
and the place.
Not always a comfortable
relationship, either.
Freud had very mixed
feelings about his hometown,
or where he lived most
of his life, Vienna.
Socrates loved Athens and was
put to death by the Athenians.
So it's a tense relationship,
but it is a relationship.
So if you look around the world,
you look at a map historically,
what do you see?
You don't see one genius popping
up in Montana, one in Bolivia,
and one in Redwood City.
You know, you see
genius clusters, right?
Certain moments
in time and place
where you had just a
lot of brilliant minds
and great ideas blossoming
for some reason.
And my book is largely
about those clusters.
What was in the water back then?
Or if you like, what
were they smoking?
Um, but let's stick with--
let's stick with the water.
What was in the water back then,
and can we bottle it, you know?
What lessons can
we learn from it?
So the book is a-- it's
a travel book because I
travel to these places.
It's a historical book
because I travel back in time.
It's a social science
book because I
read a lot of really dense,
boring papers on psychology
of creativity so
you don't have to
and try to distill the essence
of the lessons from it.
And it's a kind of selfish
book on my part because, look.
It's too late for
me to be a genius.
That ship has sailed.
But I have an
11-year-old daughter,
and it's not too late for her.
And she happens to be
adopted from Kazakhstan,
so my wife and I don't
provide the genes,
the nurture-- I'm sorry.
We don't provide the nature.
We provide the
nurture, 100% nurture.
And so I wanted to know, can we
learn lessons from these places
and apply them to our lives?
So I'll just talk
briefly about some
of the places I visited,
some of the lessons
I learned, and then I want to
open it up to conversation,
to a discussion.
Because if there's one
thing I've learned,
it's that genius
is a conversation.
It is a discussion.
Let's take a look
at Athens, sort
of the cradle of
Western civilization
and certainly a genius cluster.
Couple of observations about it.
One is if you were to go back
to just before the Golden
Age of Athens and look around
at the Greek city-states--
and there were
hundreds of them--
you would not bet on Athens.
You would not bet on Athens, OK?
The land was not
exactly fertile.
In fact, it was pretty
arid and barren.
There were other city-states
that were wealthier.
They were stronger
militarily, like Sparta.
It was not the biggest.
So you wouldn't bet on Athens.
But it had a few
things going for it.
One is it had an
outward orientation.
It had-- well, it had
the Port of Piraeus,
and they were great sailors.
And they borrowed/stole
ideas from others.
The truth is that not
that much was actually
invented in ancient Athens.
Not statuary.
They borrowed that
from the Egyptians.
Or mathematics.
They borrowed that
from elsewhere.
Or even drama.
What they did was perfected it.
Plato said what the Greeks
borrow from foreigners,
they perfect.
You could argue-- and I'll
get to this in a bit--
that Silicon Valley is
somewhat the same way.
That it's not necessarily
where ideas are born,
but where they come of age.
Which you could
argue-- I would argue
is actually more important.
They had-- this
discussion element
took place in symposia,
which literally
means drinking together.
So next time you're invited to
a symposium, keep that in mind.
And a brief aside about
alcohol, if we may,
because they actually--
the Greeks drank,
but they watered down
their wine five parts water
to two parts wine.
Perhaps knowing, as
studies show today,
that a little bit
of alcohol does
increase creative thinking,
but a lot of alcohol
makes you fall down and doesn't
produce much creativity at all.
But these were free-- these
were mainly discussions.
And I really do believe that
if alcohol or beverages,
whether it's coffee in the
coffee houses of Vienna
or the Dana Street
roastery which
is my favorite place
in Mountain View,
it's a place for people to
get together and discuss.
And in the symposia
in Athens, they
discussed everything,
everything under the sun.
Poetry, philosophy,
whatever it was.
And the real heart of the city
was the agora, the marketplace,
where people came to trade.
Philosophers were selling
their wares as well.
And so another thing they
did, which sounds very basic,
is they walked.
There was the peripatetic
school of philosophy,
which literally was a
walking school of philosophy,
walking and talking.
And it turns out a lot of
geniuses have been big walkers.
Charles Dickens would walk
through the streets of London
in the middle of the
night, turning over
the plot of "A Christmas
Carol," or whatever story
he was working on,
while the city slept.
Mark Twain paced a lot.
And down the road in
Stanford recently,
they did a study that looked
at the effects of walking
and creative thinking, and found
that spending as little as 10
or 15 minutes on a
treadmill-- not even
outdoors-- on a treadmill
staring at a blank wall
will lead to more
of what's known
as divergent thinking,
creative thinking,
than if you're
just sitting still.
The Greeks didn't
know any of this.
They didn't know any
of these studies.
But they sort of
knew it intuitively.
Ultimately, Athens collapsed.
And as I like to say,
these genius clusters all
arised for different
reasons, but they
collapsed for the
same reason, which
is arrogance, what one historian
called a creeping vanity.
It sort of seeps in.
And I think all golden ages,
including this one, which
I consider a golden
age in Silicon Valley,
have to really be on guard
against arrogance and vanity.
Which that's why I like
the phrase creeping
vanity, because it just
sort of sneaks up on you.
Let's talk about it.
Let's fast forward back to
Florence and to the Medicis
that I was speaking
about earlier.
The fact is that
genius takes money.
It takes some money.
But it has to be
leveraged wisely.
And the Medicis were
expert at doing that.
A good example is,
again, Michelangelo
who was chosen by Pope Julius
II, who was a Medici himself,
to paint the Sistine Chapel,
which we know of course admire.
We all admire it.
But Michelangelo was
not the obvious choice.
OK, he was mainly a sculptor.
He had focused on statuary.
He did some painting,
but not a lot.
Nothing on that scale.
But what the Pope did
was bet on Michelangelo.
Give him an impossible task.
Give an unlikely person
an impossible task.
And I don't know if
we do that today.
We tend-- I'm not talking
about here at Google,
but elsewhere perhaps.
There's a caution.
There's a safety
attitude of, I'm
going to hire someone for job
X who has done job X before.
Not hire someone who's done job
X for job Y. The Medicis didn't
see it that way.
But they placed a lot of wise
bets, and they knew their art,
and they leveraged
their money wisely.
They also valued the manuscripts
from the ancient world,
from Greece and Rome.
And a book back then
cost the equivalent
of what a car would cost today.
So if you owned
100 books, it would
be like owning 100 cars today.
It would be like, being,
I guess, Jerry Seinfeld
who owns 100 cars.
But you had to know cars.
You have to know
books back then.
And they would mine
the books for wisdom
and then take it
to the next level.
And they borrowed from
foreigners as well.
But what they borrowed from
foreigners, they perfected.
We're hopping around the
world and around time here,
so I hope you
don't get whiplash.
I want to talk about one
city that actually reminds me
of Silicon Valley a
lot, and that Edinburgh,
Scotland in the late
18th century, right?
This is the Scottish
Enlightenment.
Some people call it the
Scotch Enlightenment
because they drank
a lot of scotch.
But we'll call it by its
proper name, the Scottish
Enlightenment.
So in this city of
45,000 people, small even
by the standards of its day, it
was-- or there's a good quote
here from a contemporary
Scottish writer.
Tells you what it was
like in Edinburgh just
before this golden age.
The city was inconvenient,
dirty, old fashioned,
alcoholic,
quarrelsome, and poor.
Oosh.
Yet it blossomed.
It was the Silicon
Valley of its day
in that it was far removed
from the center of Europe
on the fringes.
Silicon Valley, it's
not a coincidence
it grew up out west.
A place where, as one of the
early founders of Silicon
Valley said, out here if you
fail, your family won't know
and your neighbors won't care.
All right?
And there was some
of that in Edinburgh.
There was also, to get
back to this conversation,
it took place everywhere.
They had hundreds of
clubs, strange clubs,
like the 717 Club, where
they met at only 7:17 PM.
The Oyster Club, which was
founded by Adam Smith and David
Hume, the philosopher.
They would eat oysters,
which was considered
peasant food, drink claret,
red wine, and converse
about everything.
And there was a lack
of specialization.
That was true in Athens,
that was true in Florence,
it was true in Edinburgh.
And it's true that the fields
of sociology and geology
and economics were all very
young back then, right?
So people had not
yet built fortresses
around their little
parcels of knowledge.
I think that the reason we
don't have a Renaissance man
today-- or woman
today-- is largely
because of specialization.
And at a dinner
party the other day
a friend said, well, of course
there's more specialization
today.
The world's more complicated.
I would argue the world is more
complicated because there's
more specialization.
That specialization
certainly contributes
to the complicated
world we live in,
that people are rewarded
for knowing more
and more about less and less.
That was not the
case in Edinburgh.
And sort of the digital
technology of the day
was actually medicine.
The school in
Edinburgh University
was the place for medicine.
They were advances
in anesthesia,
and in all sorts of fields.
And there was experimentation
and risk taking going on.
There was a physician
named James Simpson
who wanted to test a
new type of anesthetic.
And he had his friends over
for, like, a dinner party,
and offered them
a liquid beverage.
And apparently in Scotland,
people don't ask any questions.
They will just drink
what's given to them.
Turns out it was chloroform,
liquid chloroform.
And the next morning the maid
found everyone passed out.
He was lucky, because
any less and maybe they
wouldn't feel the
anesthetic effects anymore.
They would have all been killed.
Within a few years, chloroform
became the most widely used
form of anesthesia.
But if you think about
it, it makes sense
that medicine has a
theoretical side, but also
a practical side.
And the Scots were
great improvers.
In fact, it was the
age of improvement.
You know, they began with
building a better plow.
They went on to
the steam engine.
James Watt didn't actually
invent the steam engine.
He invented a
better steam engine.
And that reminded me of
Silicon Valley as well.
There was also a lot of
complementary skills going on.
There's-- I call this
compensatory genius.
I was going to give an example,
but it involves a competing
company down the road.
I won't give that example.
[LAUGHTER]
But two guys named
Steve, and one's better
at something than the other.
But no last names.
The example in Edinburgh is
the founder of modern geology
was a man named James
Hutton, who was brilliant.
I mean, he was the
first one to suggest,
through field research and
hard digging, literal digging
as well as
metaphorical, that, hey.
Maybe the Earth is older than
6,000 years as the Bible says,
and as everyone just
believed back then.
Maybe it's a lot older.
As of course we know it is
now, but it was a radical idea.
He wrote up his paper.
The problem was that Hutton was
a terrible, terrible writer.
Turgid, dry prose.
Nobody could get through it.
But he had a friend
named John Playfair
who had a way with words.
He spiced up his paper, made
it much more compelling.
Ultimately presented it to the
Royal Society of Edinburgh.
And those ideas went on to
influence Darwin and Darwin's
theory of natural selection.
Compensatory genius.
One genius compensating for
the shortcomings of another.
And usually one gets more credit
than the other, unfortunately.
But throughout history
in all these places,
there are always
invisible helpers,
people who are working
behind the scenes.
In Florence, it was-- well,
Lorenzo wasn't exactly
totally invisible.
But a priest named
Niccolo Bichiellini was.
He worked in a church
called Santo Spirito.
And Michelangelo was just coming
into his own as a sculptor,
and he wanted to understand
how the human body worked.
And the only way to
really understand it--
it's a little disgusting,
but it's true--
is to dissect a cadaver
and figure it out.
That was absolutely forbidden.
The Church would not allow it.
But he went to the Church
of Santo Spirito, which
also had a mortuary
and a hospital,
as churches did then,
and said to the priest,
I'd like to dissect a cadaver.
The priest agreed, under
the cover of darkness,
to allow Michelangelo to
do that, which gave him
the understanding
of the anatomy,
gave him the ability
to ultimately sculpt
the "David," which
we all admire today.
So you have to give credit
to people like Bichiellini,
to these invisible helpers.
And so to sum up, before
we go to questions,
I believe that in all creative
places and all places where
you see genius, there
are invisible helpers.
There is a creative ecology,
an actual ecology in place.
And that it is the process that
matters more than the product.
The product of the
Renaissance was largely art.
But the process-- I'm sorry.
The product-- yeah.
The product was art.
The process was a particular
way of bringing that art
to fruition.
The product of this
place, of Silicon Valley,
is largely technology.
But I don't believe Silicon
Valley is about technology
at all.
It is about a creative ecology.
It is about a way of
bringing ideas to fruition.
I'm generally wary of tying
things up in a neat bow
and saying, OK.
Here are three Ts with three Bs.
But I realize people
like [INAUDIBLE].
So at the end of my book
I have the three Ds,
and I'll just discuss
them very briefly here
about what I think all
these places have in common,
these genius clusters.
And then I want to
go to your questions.
The three D's are Diversity,
Discernment, Disorder.
Diversity, not only
ethnic diversity.
In fact, I would argue
that ethnic diversity
is less important than
intellectual diversity.
Diversity of ideas,
that openness
to experience that
psychologists have identified
as the single most important
trait for creativity,
for creative people and
for creative places.
Diversity and openness.
Number two is
discernment, which tends
to get less attention than
diversity and openness.
But you can't just
have a lot of ideas
and treat them all equally,
like they're all equally good.
They're not.
Jonas Salk, two time-- no.
Two time Nobel Prize winner was
asked by a student, Dr. Salk,
how do you come up with
so many good ideas?
And Jonas Salk said,
well, it's easy.
You come up with lots of ideas
and you throw out the bad ones.
But you need to throw
out the bad ones.
So these genius clusters
are magnets, yes.
But they're also colanders
that sift out the bad ideas
and leave the good.
Disorder.
As I mentioned, these
were unlikely places,
these golden ages.
And their golden age
was often preceded
by disruption and disorder.
In the case of Athens, it was
the Persian War, which they
won, but their city was sacked.
I mean, Athens was burnt
to the ground, which
meant it had to be
rebuilt. And Pericles
built it much, much better.
Built the Acropolis, which
we still admire today.
In Florence, it was the
bubonic plague, which wiped out
a third of the population.
But two generations later,
you've got the Renaissance.
And I think there's a
connection, because you
need a stirring of the pot.
And there's a lot of
fascinating research
out there in the
early stages looking
at the connection between
chaos theory and creativity.
And there is a connection.
Chaos, I believe,
is a necessary state
to pass through in order
to get to a new order.
And that chaos is something--
you see this with geniuses
on a personal level.
If you've seen-- well,
Einstein's hair or Beethoven's
apartments-- well, he had
multiple apartments in Vienna
and they were total
pig stys and messes.
And there have
been studies done--
and this will be
reassuring for people
who have messy desks-- that
show in a messy office setting,
you will think more
creatively than in a neat one.
You may think creatively.
I don't know if you get those
ideas down on a screen or not.
That's another story.
So diversity,
disorder, discernment.
It's a simplification.
It's a little bow.
There's a lot more
to it than that.
It's all in here.
And it's fun too.
I mean, I think that
researching a serious topic
like creative genius can
be fun, and I have fun.
I meet some amazing
characters on the road.
And I approach the book the
way Socrates suggests it,
from a place of ignorance.
That the only thing I
know is that I don't know,
and then I set out to learn.
And so with that, I'd be
happy to take any questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
ERIC WEINER: You're welcome.
MALE SPEAKER: And before
we open it up more widely,
you've written two
geography books now,
"The Geography of Bliss" and
"The Geography of Genius."
I was wondering what you think
are sort of any intersections
or common themes which
are good for both,
and any contradictions,
if you will?
ERIC WEINER: Well,
Switzerland's a good example.
One of the happiest
countries in the world
statistically, if you
look at the surveys.
And it's included in my book
"The Geography of Bliss."
But as Graham Greene said about
Switzerland, ah, the Swiss.
500 years of peace and
democracy, and what have they
brought the world
but the cuckoo clock?
Which is actually not true.
The Germans invented
the cuckoo clock.
[LAUGHTER]
I think there's probably,
like, if it's a Venn diagram,
is there an intersection between
happiness and creative genius?
A little bit.
I think if you're
really-- a lot of geniuses
have been depressives, right?
They've suffered from
manic depression,
they've suffered from
clinical depression.
But they don't really do
their most creative work
when they're really in the
throes of the black dog,
as depression's been called.
So I think a little bit of that
unhappiness and instability
is good.
But you can be a happy genius
too, a relatively happy genius.
I think there's some overlap.
But I think someone or someplace
that was perfectly happy--
say paradise.
If paradise existed,
it would probably
be the least creative
place in the world.
Because creativity, I believe,
is a reaction to a challenge.
And there are no challenges
in paradise, right?
Everything is given to you.
So like so many things in
this book, it is a sweet spot.
A sweet spot between being an
insider and being an outsider.
I write about immigrant--
[INAUDIBLE] immigrants
and creativity.
And sweet spot between
happiness and misery, basically.
Other questions?
MALE SPEAKER: Questions?
Yeah.
ERIC WEINER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you're
trying to anticipate where
the next, like, locus of
genius would be, well,
are you willing to do that?
And what would you look for?
ERIC WEINER: I
could say anything.
You know, I think--
this question comes up,
and you know, I could say,
like, Ecuador, but not
for another 10,000 years.
[LAUGHTER]
That would be the safest bet.
The honest answer
is, I don't know.
But we can say with-- not to
pick on the North Koreans.
I don't know if there's anyone
from North Korea here today.
But it's not going to
be North Korea, OK?
It's not going to be a
place like North Korea.
We can say that.
It's not going to be a
closed system like that.
It's going to be an open--
place with an open system,
and a place with a
culture, a strong culture.
Let's look at
Estonia, for instance.
OK, usually people
don't know this,
but I'm willing to bet
100% of people in the room
know that Skype was
developed in Estonia.
That seems odd to some people.
Small country, but
small can be good.
A strong culture.
They were never really russified
under the Soviet Union.
Open, free flow of information,
geographically well positioned.
It's between Russia
and Western Europe.
That strikes me as a place
where things can happen.
But the specific
place-- I mean, I
would be lying to you
if I were to say, it's
going to be right there.
What I can say is
that it will not
be manufactured, this place.
It will not be contrived.
This has been tried.
You know about Silicon
Wadi, Thames Valley.
There have been so many attempts
to replicate this place,
and they have all failed because
I believe Silicon Valley is
a culture, and you cannot
transplant a culture.
It just doesn't work that way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So universities will
traditionally fit those three
Ds that you talk about, right?
Generally, a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] have the culture.
So [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC WEINER: Yeah.
I would take a little
exception with that.
But is your question about--
AUDIENCE: I'm just
wondering-- I mean,
what are the track
record of universities
through history [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIC WEINER: Yeah.
That's an interesting question,
because the relationship
between, say, education
and genius is curvilinear.
A little bit of education's
good, but a lot is not so good.
In fact--
[LAUGHTER]
No, I'm serious.
And that's true with
happiness, by the way, too.
If you have a PhD, you are
statistically less likely to be
a genius than if you don't.
And by the way, you're
statistically less
likely to be happy than--
[LAUGHTER]
--than someone with
just a master's degree.
But if you think
about it, I think
this is not a coincidence.
Because you are-- you're
specializing, right?
More and more.
And there's a long line of
geniuses who were bad students.
Einstein was-- he
hated high school.
I mean, he almost
gave up science
because of the exam system,
which he found stifling.
He had difficulty getting his
PhD dissertation accepted.
And I mean, I won't
name names here,
but Silicon Valley is littered
with college dropouts.
Woody Allen was college dropout.
One of the courses he
failed was film at NYU.
But it makes sense in the level
that if a university represents
the status quo, the status
quo of knowledge and learning,
and the genius is
upsetting that status quo,
they're going to have to
be outside the system.
There are exceptions.
This could go back to Edinburgh.
The university played
a helpful role there,
partly because it was an
entrepreneurial university
system.
Like Stanford and Fred
Terman under Stanford
who broke down the wall between
commerce and university.
In Edinburgh, professors
got paid on commission.
The more students
they had in the class,
the more they got paid.
And they would use the students
to test fly their theories.
Adam Smith first
presented his ideas, which
are found in "The
Wealth of Nations,"
to a group of students
who were-- average age
was 14 or 15 years old.
So that was a pretty-- if it's
the right kind of university
system, it can play
a positive role.
But the track record is not
as clear as what you'd think,
that just more education
equals more creative genius.
It doesn't work that way.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In your
research, did you
come across any patterns that
caused the slow of growth
in creative genius?
Like, when did Athens become
not a place to do that?
ERIC WEINER: I think
it was arrogance.
It was this creeping vanity.
And that's what happened is
either places become arrogant
and therefore they
become less ignorant,
which is bad-- they close
their mind to the possibility
of possibility because
they're convinced
they know exactly how do it.
There's also this kind of
obscure theory from the 1940
called configurations of culture
growth by this anthropologist
named Kroeber.
And the way I
translate his ideas,
it's like you have
a kitchen cupboard,
and you're trying to cook.
And ultimately-- you can combine
them in different ways, right?
You know, there are
those apps where
you put in the
ingredients you have,
and they give you
dishes you can make.
At some point, you run out
of combinations, right?
So you have to import
more ingredients
or do something drastic.
But at some point, cultures just
start to plagiarize themselves.
And so I say either
arrogance or kind
of a staleness, the staleness
that comes from closing off.
Athens was very
open to foreigners
during its golden age, and
then it became less so.
They also-- I should
issue this is a warning.
You could trace their decline to
when they became real foodies.
Because before, they
were not foodies at all.
No, really.
They had, like, very plain,
bland food, a meager diet.
And Aristophanes, the
satirical playwright,
attributed their genius
to their meager diet.
Then they got into--
you know, started
shopping at Williams-Sonoma.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
--or the equivalent back then.
It's being a little flippant,
but you think about it
like there's an opportunity cost
to all your creative energy.
If you put it all into
cooking, how much more
do you have left
over for poetry?
I don't know.
Anyway.
Hope that helps.
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you looked
classical cultures
and I guess post-Renaissance
or enlightenment cultures.
Did you look at anything like
Arabic or Chinese cultures
around, say, 1000 AD?
Places where there are lots
and lots of creative genius
and that seemed to fade?
ERIC WEINER: I went
to China and focused
on Hangzhou China, which
was the capital of the Song
dynasty in the 13th century.
A city that blew away
Marco Polo, for one.
He wrote about it.
And they invented-- essentially
invented the compass.
Wood block printing was
invented and first used
in Buddhist monasteries.
It was a city of
a million people.
A million people
in the year, like,
1250 when the biggest city in
Europe was maybe 50,000 people.
And it was remarkable.
And I-- I mean, I get into
some of the differences
between Eastern--
Eastern-- Chinese Confucian
views on creativity
and Western views.
And there's a lot of
interesting research on this.
A lot of our views
about creativity
come from our creationists.
Judeo Christian, in the
case of this country.
Whether you're religious
or not, whether you're
Judeo or Christian.
I mean, this idea of creation ex
nihilo, something from nothing,
is really part of our DNA,
speaking metaphorically, DNA.
But in China, the
creation myth is
that there's always
been something,
and always will be something.
That's a more cyclical
view, and you're just
sort of rearranging it.
So they've always had, I
think, a more gradual approach
to innovation, which
I find interesting.
And one of the
conclusions I reach
is that creative places
and creative people
were always more solidly rooted
in tradition than we think,
even this place.
That Isaac Newton
famously said he
could see so far by standing
on the shoulders of giants.
Well, we're always standing
on the shoulders of giants,
whether we
acknowledge it or not.
In China, and to some
extent in India--
you know, in the Indian
creation myth at the beginning,
there was chaos, actually.
That's their myth.
Anyway, I do address--
I made a point
to try to get out of Western
Europe and to go to China.
And I go to Calcutta in the
20th-- late 19th, early 20th
century to look at the
Bengal Renaissance.
And I go to Vienna and
look at the musical genius
and the genius of Freud and
others of 1900, and Scotland.
And I end up here.
Yes?
Almost have the
[INAUDIBLE] right here.
AUDIENCE: This is
more an observation,
and I was just wondering
if you could comment on it.
I sort of see a
running theme here
about looking at the
role of the urban space
and the city space as central
to the kinds of movements
that you're describing, right?
ERIC WEINER: Right.
AUDIENCE: And I'm also
hearing these ideas
about the urban commons
and a culture that
encourages walking and
sort of ad hoc running
into people with whom you can
have a conversation, et cetera.
And here in America,
the last 50 years
we have flown to
suburbia, and we have
cities that get interesting.
The immediate sort
of thing that happens
after that is gentrification
because the spaces
are getting interesting again.
And I was always-- I was
really pleasantly surprised
visiting Sydney earlier this
year, earlier last year,
and looking at how
the city was really
built around walking and
taking public transportation,
and entering large,
open spaces in the heart
of the city, et cetera.
And I just feel like--
especially, you know,
I don't know if
you know about sort
of debates in San Francisco
about who's city is it,
and what's happening to it?
I just feel like the way we
are dealing with urban space
planning and the culture of
urban spaces are interesting.
They're not conducive
to the kind of-- yeah.
From what I'm hearing,
they're not conducive.
Or is it not?
ERIC WEINER: Well, if
there's less mixing going on.
I mean, cities-- it's
been said that cities
are where ideas go to have sex.
Which--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC WEINER: Yeah.
And there's some truth to that.
But you need to have-- to carry
this metaphor perhaps a little
too far, you need to have
different ideas having sex
and not just the same two.
And you need to have a
mix of things going on.
degree of trust and intimacy.
Because you know, there's
a very strong theory
out there about
density and creativity,
that it's all really
about density.
Like molecules in a container.
The more molecules you have
moving around very fast,
bounce into each other, forming
different compounds, then
the more molecules you have, the
more interesting combinations
you'll get.
And it's called
interaction opportunities.
And I see some-- definitely
there's some validity to that.
But prisons are
dense places too.
Slums-- no.
The slums of-- slums
of Mumbai, right?
There's the famous one
right near the airport.
You know--
AUDIENCE: Dharavi.
ERIC WEINER: Dharavi, right.
Dharavi slum is
incredibly dense.
And I'm not denying there's
some creativity going
on in terms of
how people survive
to get through each day.
But there's not a lot of
genius, as we would call it,
coming out of there.
So it takes more
than just density.
I think it takes some
intimacy and trust, right?
You need to trust someone
enough to share their ideas.
An interesting little factoid,
if you will, that I came across
is a study that found that
we cooperate best with those
with whom we once competed.
With cooperate best
with former competitors.
It seems to be the
case here where
there's a lot of that going on.
Because you've built up actually
some trust through competition.
So I don't if I'm directly
answering your question.
But cities are important.
Designing cities-- if you look
at the cities around the world
that truly are artificial,
like Brasilia or Ankara
or Islamabad, they tend
to be not the most vibrant
creatively, right?
It needs to be
something organic.
But one mystery--
and I have to admit,
there are plenty of mysteries
remaining in this book--
is this place, Silicon Valley.
It's the one outlier.
Did not begin as a city, right?
Began as orchards.
Began as farmland
and small towns.
And that's the exception.
You really would have expected,
if you look historically
at all these places
I did, you would
have expected Silicon Valley to
begin on Market Street in San
Francisco and to
spread down here,
and not to go the other way.
I haven't figured
that one out yet.
So if you have
ideas, let me know.
Yes?
Drink of water, one second.
AUDIENCE: So your
[INAUDIBLE] diversity.
That's the new
concept [INAUDIBLE].
Do you think these places
that you identified
have more diversity in
some sense, [INAUDIBLE]
maybe more travelers
will come to the place
or different
religions [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIC WEINER:
Immigration, I would say.
I mean, first diversity
of people, which
leads to diversity of ideas.
And I've written-- I wrote an
article in the "Wall Street
Journal" this past weekend
about this connection
between immigration
and creative genius.
And there's a long list
of immigrants and refugees
who've become
geniuses, you know?
Whether it's Thomas
Mann or Einstein who
was twice over an immigrant.
Marie Curie, who moved
from Poland to Paris.
And so what is it about the
immigrant experience that
makes them creative?
And it's not just
that they work hard.
I mean, that might
explain their success,
but doesn't explain
the creative leap.
I think it's because their world
has been turned upside down.
They're bringing a
fresh perspective.
And they bring
diversity to a place,
and then that has like a
contagion effect, actually.
It's not that immigrants
just bring their ideas
and everyone says, oh.
They use chopsticks in China.
We're going to use
chopsticks here.
No.
It's like, oh.
There's some other
way of eating other
than using a fork and
spoon, and maybe there's
other ways of
doing other things.
So it opens your mind to the
possibility of possibility.
And that, I think, is the
real value of diversity
and of immigration.
It's not that, oh.
We're just going to import
that idea wholesale.
We might adopt that idea-- adapt
it rather, to our own needs.
Or we might just
find another field.
I mean, there's a creativity
contagion that goes on.
Like Vienna of 1900s,
a perfect example.
So you had the
Secessionist movement
in art led by Gustav Klimt.
A whole new art movement.
And then you've got
advances in physics
and you've got Freud
with his theories.
And what happens is I think
people see breakthroughs
in one field and they lead
to breakthroughs in others.
And perhaps you see that here
in Silicon Valley as well.
Yes?
OK, Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I have--
I have equations.
So the recent academic
Joseph Tainter who studied,
tried to make some sort of a
quantitative study of, let's
say, creative throughput.
So he and a few other
academics set up
this database of
all the US patents
and then tried to analyze
it, then tried to see what--
ERIC WEINER: Yeah,
this sounds familiar.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: --what
trends they can see.
And what they found out is this
decrease in [INAUDIBLE]-- well,
a decrease in number of patents
for scientific [INAUDIBLE]
or engineering [INAUDIBLE].
So-- and he was really trying
to study sort of creativity,
but that's a proxy.
He can study creativity.
ERIC WEINER: It gives
you some numbers.
Data, right?
Everyone loves data.
AUDIENCE: And he sort
of explains it partly
in the following way.
He says at the time
of Newton or Darwin,
you could have sort of a loan,
reasonably wealthy person
with a laboratory
in the basement
and making really
impactful inventions.
And he says now
that time is gone.
You really need very
expensive equipment.
You need a--
ERIC WEINER: Specialization.
AUDIENCE: --specialization.
You need a lot of people
helping you to operate.
And so he basically
says, well, there
are these-- there are these
great, impactful inventions.
He calls them,
like, [INAUDIBLE].
Like a lightbulb.
So that was already invented,
and gravity was already
[INAUDIBLE] gravity
was discovered.
And he says now the inventions
are sort of further--
more difficult to make.
And so-- and he isn't
making a statement.
He's sort of asking questions.
In one of the lectures
he's asks, well,
is it the case-- I mean, is
the creative sort of throughput
coming to-- becoming diminished?
Do we need to invest
more and more resources
to have the same level
of creative throughput?
And so what is your sense?
ERIC WEINER: Well, I mean,
there-- it's definitely--
it's true, and it's been shown
by other researchers too that
we're-- we have fewer
real breakthroughs, right?
Where is the Darwin or
the Einstein of our day
who make a real leap?
And I think it's because
of specializations.
Because, as you say, it's more
expensive to-- even though
in a lot of fields
like the digital fields
that you work in, it's
much easier for anyone
to get involved, I suppose,
to find a cure for cancer
or to do some real
breakthrough work.
The costs have actually gotten
higher, you could argue.
So there are fewer
scientific breakthroughs
today than in centuries past.
I think we've raised the floor.
Like, there are more talented
people in centuries past.
But we've actually
lowered the ceiling.
I would point a finger
again at specialization,
that even a Darwin was crossing
over boundaries from botany
to biology that
maybe today there
would be a wall between them.
Einstein was
crossing boundaries.
I think we need to have
more of a porousness
and an amateur culture in a way.
This place, Silicon
Valley, grew out
of tinkering, first
with ham radio
and then with motherboards.
But if it requires
an institution
and a big, expensive institution
to make a breakthrough,
you're going to have
fewer breakthroughs.
I mean, Google would
have never started
if it required an
institution to start it.
Yes sir?
AUDIENCE: So I have
read your previous--
ERIC WEINER: Oh, sorry.
Oh, hold on.
One question here.
I didn't-- I'm sorry.
I apologize.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to go
back to your-- the earlier
question about decline of
creative locations today.
And so you talked about Athens,
it being arrogance and maybe
a declining interest in
other ideas, outside ideas.
And I think there's some saying,
as will happen in phases.
That's happening now
in Silicon Valley,
or there are signs of it.
What's your take on that?
Do you see any signs of
those things happening?
ERIC WEINER: I was
waiting for this question.
AUDIENCE: Or other
signs of decline?
ERIC WEINER: I was actually
pleasantly surprised
so many questions have been
not about Silicon Valley.
I'm thinking about what I say
and whether I'll be invited
back based on what I say.
How about just an
honest answer, yes.
I do see some of that.
I think-- I lived in Palo
Alto about a decade ago.
I was at Stanford University
doing a fellowship.
And since that decade
when I come back,
I see more bling, for
lack of a better word.
Flashiness.
And I think bling
is antithetical
to creative genius.
You need the constraints
and the hardship.
Every company that's
admired in the Valley,
whether it's Hewlett and Packard
in their garage, you know,
or your two founders,
you know, they
didn't work in great
circumstances, right?
They had constraints.
And once you remove
all those constraints
and you replace
it with bling, you
might slip into arrogance
and complacency.
But I think people are on
guard about it here, right?
I think especially
what Silicon Valley
does well is it appreciates
the value of smallness, right?
And help me out here, but
isn't there an attempt
to keep work groups
small, to work in teams?
To create-- just looking
around at the architecture
of the place, there are
lots of small spaces.
I mean, it's a big,
sprawling campus,
but with lots of
nooks and crannies.
And nooks and crannies are
where creativity happens.
I think that's good.
I think immigration is still
a big part of life here.
Half of all Silicon
Valley startups
have at least one founder
who's born outside of US.
That's important.
There's an outward orientation.
I mean, look at the faces
and the accents in this room.
I mean, to me that's
proof positive that it's
doing some things right.
But-- I mean, I hate
to be the bummer,
but looking historically,
these golden ages
don't last that long.
They're pretty fragile
and perishable.
A few decades, a
few generations,
maybe a century or so.
And Silicon Valley's
had a good run.
And I'm not
predicting its demise,
but you can't-- you know, I'm
sure in Athens at its peak
and Renaissance Florence, they
never thought that they would
see their end any more than
people in Detroit did in 1950.
So I see some signs, but
I also see some awareness
of those signs, which is good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My question's
about competition.
There was only one Athens at
the time of Athens, and only one
Edinburgh at the
time of Edinburgh.
If there are several, say,
Google, Apple, Facebook, et
cetera competing at the
same time, and each of them
is being a genius
nurturer, and they all
know that another institution
will eat their lunch if they
don't keep that
genius, can that help
to reduce the creeping vanity?
ERIC WEINER: Well, I
mean, there was one Athens
that we remember.
Of course, there were many
city-states and they--
we remember the winners, right?
So-- but yeah.
Competition is like one
of the trickiest aspects
of this genius puzzle,
because the research
in the lab sort of contradicts
the research in the real world,
or the other way around.
I'll give you an example.
There's this theory called the
theory of intrinsic motivation.
And psychologists at Harvard
have done a lot of work
with their colleagues on this.
And essentially-- I'm
simplifying here--
but they'll have
people in a lab,
undergrads usually,
looking for money.
You know?
But that's OK.
They're valid.
And one group will be given
material to build a collage,
and said, OK.
You're going to build a collage,
and you'll be graded on it.
If you build a particularly
good one, you'll receive money
and your name will
be publicized.
Extrinsic motivation.
The other group is told, here.
Same material.
Build a collage.
Just have fun, you know?
And they find consistently
it's that second group that
is told just to have
fun that produces
the more creative work.
That doesn't jive with what
I've found in these places.
Like, Athens was competitive.
The Greeks brought us the
Olympics, for crying out loud.
Florence was hugely competitive.
Michelangelo and
Leonardo, for instance,
hated each other's
guts, but yet it
brought out the best in them.
And look at this place.
I don't live and work
here, but I imagine
it's a little bit competitive.
No?
Yes.
[LAUGH]
But also cooperative, right?
There's that combination.
And I found one study that
I think explains a lot.
Those collage studies
tend to focus on--
to use people who are
novices to building collages.
But one study
looked at musicians,
but looked at
experienced musicians
and found that with
when they were told to
improvise a piece of music,
and one group was given
intrinsic motivation, have fun,
and the other, extrinsic
motivation, cash, recognition,
the second group did well.
So my working theory on this
is if you're a beginner,
if you're starting out
playing the violin or coding,
competition's not good.
You're going to freeze up.
It's going to paralyze you.
But once you achieve
a degree of mastery,
the competition is good.
And on a societal scale or
a place, geographic scale,
what do you have here?
You have competition,
but competition
among people who have achieved
some mastery in their field.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: To achieve mastery
in the musician field
requires lots of
intrinsic motivation
and lots of specialization.
So I think you're looking at a
very select population there.
ERIC WEINER: Hm.
Well, let me-- I'm going to
turn the question and ask you.
Do you think that
competition plays
a positive role in Silicon
Valley, for instance?
AUDIENCE: Well, you said earlier
that in paradise, there's
no challenges.
ERIC WEINER: Right.
AUDIENCE: You're not
talking about engineers.
We love challenges.
We are intrinsically motivated.
ERIC WEINER: OK.
But are you
extrinsically motivated
by, say, being number one?
AUDIENCE: No.
ERIC WEINER: No?
AUDIENCE: Being excellent, yes.
Being number one, no.
ERIC WEINER: OK.
But that excellence comes
from your internal compass,
not from an external validation?
I'm just wondering.
I'm seriously curious.
AUDIENCE: It helps to be able to
measure it, because otherwise,
how do I know?
ERIC WEINER: Right.
AUDIENCE: But I don't
compete with people.
I compete with the
highest standard
I can find and attain to.
ERIC WEINER: Hm.
OK.
I mean, that-- you sound like
you're intrinsically motivated.
But what if Google cut
your salary in half?
[LAUGH]
All right.
We've got a real
intrinsic motivator here.
That's maybe-- yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I have
read your other book
"The Geography of Bliss."
ERIC WEINER: Right.
AUDIENCE: And I wanted to know
if you make any connection
between bliss and genius.
Does it happen [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIC WEINER: Yeah,
that came up earlier.
I think you weren't here.
But there's a little bit
of overlap but not a lot.
I think if you're
totally blissed out,
if on a scale of one
to ten, you're a 10,
I don't see those people
being the most creative.
But if you're one or two
and you're not getting out
of bed in the
morning, you're not
going to create much either.
Yes?
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Go ahead.
We're almost out of time.
ERIC WEINER: OK.
This has been great, through.
AUDIENCE: I was quickly
going to ask, to what extent
does the diversity or the
spectrum, the range of ideas
qualify these places
as clusters of genius.
I mean, Florence, you had
everything from accounting
to-- and in Vienna you
had all of the arts.
And so these are
very diverse places.
Is it sufficient that you
optimize the [INAUDIBLE]
to be-- you know, I
mean, [INAUDIBLE]--
ERIC WEINER: Optimize
the-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But what I'm saying--
ERIC WEINER: OK.
[LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So to what extent does
the diversity actually
qualify a clusterous
being, a cluster of genius?
ERIC WEINER: In my mind--
MALE SPEAKER: When you
answer, could you maybe just
summarize [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIC WEINER: Yeah.
The question is in order to
qualify as a genius cluster,
must you be a diverse
genius cluster?
In other words, do you
have to be more than just
a one-note genius cluster?
And I think so.
The only really exception
I had to that in my book
was Vienna part one, which
was musical Vienna, which
really was about music,
late 18th century.
But I think what in my mind
makes these golden ages
special is that sparks
were flying in so
many different directions.
Exactly-- and that's great.
Not many people know that
accounting, modern accounting
practices, came out of Florence
as well as all that great art.
And you see that time and
again in these places.
And I think, again, it's
that contagion effect.
It's not just a coincidence.
Because you have an art
movement in Vienna in 1900
that's amazing, you're
more likely to have
an amazing psychological
movement as well.
And the problem with
Detroit is it was one-note.
I don't-- you know, briefly when
I was looking at the US and I
was going to have a chapter
on the US, I thought, well,
do I do New Orleans and jazz?
Do I do New York and art
in the '50s and '60s?
Do I do Detroit?
And some people considered
Henry Ford a genius,
in that place of genius.
But it just seemed too narrow.
It seems like it's got to
go in different directions.
And I guess I'll
end with a question
that I'm curious
what you think about.
Is this place-- how
diverse is Silicon Valley?
Is it a one-note town or-- town.
Place, region.
Or is it many notes?
Anyone?
I mean, is it-- because
some people say, well,
it's-- you know, it's software
and hardware or its this
and that.
But it's, you know--
AUDIENCE: It's many.
ERIC WEINER: Its many things.
AUDIENCE: Bioengineering,
all kinds of engineering.
I mean, it's everything.
ERIC WEINER: Right.
I suppose what's missing
is a true art scene.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC WEINER: Right.
Although if you
expand the definition
of Silicon Valley to San
Francisco today, you do
have that there.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Would you
include Berkeley there?
Oakland?
ERIC WEINER: Yeah, I mean if
you expand it broadly enough,
you've got everything.
So I would argue that it would--
and this is just a theory-- is
that the more diverse you
are, the better your chances
of longevity, right?
Because you've diversified.
Like, it's a biological
phenomena, right?
You don't have all your
eggs in one basket.
So the more Silicon
Valley diversifies
into even adjacent fields like
biotech, et cetera, the better.
Again, I'm against
specialization.
So this has been a
great chat, though.
MALE SPEAKER: This
was fantastic.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please join me
in thanking Eric Weiner.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.